offer more word joint buy you'll save
yawning a senior policy fellow at the
European Council on Foreign Relations in
Berlin good to have you here with us so
on November the first turkey will vote
in a new or perhaps an old government
certainly incumbent president rhetoric
type erred one is trying very hard to
woo expats
especially also here in Germany offering
things like those who fly to Turkey will
get 20% of their fare reimbursed
passports will also be cheaper what's
your take on that is that economically
sound sound it's it's driven by party
instincts you know the turkish expat
community is conservative and they tend
to support arrow on because they look at
things from the outside and not from the
inside and he's very much after this
vote now Turkey and Germany there's a
very long relationship of course also
economically how important is turkey for
Germany nowadays well for an export
economy like the German when turkey is a
very interesting case because it's an
emerging economy on the doorstep of
Europe and not far away in Asia and
indeed the Turkish economic development
has been impressive with eight nine
percent growth over a number of years it
has been a tiger State which of course
is always interesting because it's it's
a large population and it's a
potentially interesting market but this
emerging market like many others by the
way has cooled down significantly I mean
you just mentioned growth figures of
nine percent know that we saw last in
2011 but by now this boom slowed
significantly in 2015 as we can see very
soon Ankara expects growth of only
around three percent now that is still
more than Germany of course so still
impressive but the science of the times
there aren't too good so what exactly is
the problem well for Turkey it's a
disaster because you know with 3% growth
but almost 10% inflation the lira losing
30 percent of its value over the course
of 2015 but still you have about a third
of the young turks under 30 unemployed
you know this country has a severe
economic
problem it has come to the end of an
economic boom it has to shape up its
governance the level of corruption is
very high but at the same time it's in a
region of crisis so also part of its
markets are destabilizing it's lacking
foreign investments but it needs a lot
of foreign investment because of its
dependency on imports of resources and
energy do you think that you membership
talks will make any difference not over
the short term membership talks of
course have helped Turkey to get where
it is today with a much shaped up public
infrastructure but over the past five
years or so the government and the
president has been slowing down in their
reform passion and they would have to
renew this so not an easy road ahead
Joseph yawning thank you very much for
being here with us